first of all marijuana doesn't make  people violent as a general rule alcohol  often does which is completely legal  alcohol is actually a major factor in  violent crime marijuana is not  legalization reduces violence it reduces  violence it is far less likely  that there will be violence when buying  pot at a hipster weed store compared to  in a back alley from Street dealers that  you don't know now their argument is if  the penalties for the dealing go down  then you are going to see more dealers  enter the market but it it's not  actually working that way because when  it's legalized and regulated the demand  for buying from Street dealers goes down  dramatically now will some people want  to pay less even when there's  legalization to go and buy for from a  street dealer who doesn't have to pay  tax yeah to some degree but the net  effect is a reduction in cannabis  distribution related violence